all right everyone let's just jump right
into it vertical networking and hot 50
let's start things off with the North
Star what the hell does that mean a
North Star is where you find the most
meaning in your life it's where you find
the most purpose the most fulfillment in
your life to identify your North Star
your unique contribution to civilization
as your puzzle piece is critical one of
the most important things for you to do
if not the most important thing to do so
identifying the North Star is first and
foremost the most important thing to do
all right let's move right on after
you've identified your North Star we
need to distinguish between vertical and
horizontal networking so what is
horizontal networking well horizontal
networking is when you do things like
network with people that are at the same
skill level as you at the same
approximate age as you and when we do
that we typically find ourselves in
especially in the high school and
collegiate days where we're between ages
like 14 and 22 even through the PhDs up
to 30 usually what we're doing is we're
hanging out with people around our age
and we're talking of other people around
the same skill level as us and really
what that does is it constrains us it
constrains us to thinking patterns that
are only within the bubbles of our peers
versus when we do things like a vertical
networking so vertical networking is
when we take ourselves way outside of
our are our horizontal peers and we go
all the way up in terms of competence in
terms of influence in terms of knowledge
and intelligence power clout all those
things so when you think of people that
you want to get in touch with that are
smarter than you that are more powerful
more influential than you that is
vertical networking and vertical
networking does not necessarily have to
be older I made this little note here
that it can be younger and smarter we
have had plenty of examples of people on
our show that we featured that have been
younger than me I'm 26 we've had people
on that have been 18
20:22 younger than me but more
intelligent than me especially in their
specific domains and so it's extremely
important to stay humble and even
vertically network with people that are
younger than you but that are more
intelligent than you in specific fields
so again vertical networking is
contacting people that you want to get
in touch with that are more intelligent
more powerful more influential have
bigger clout than you and how do you do
that right here's the question how do
you do that well identifying the list is
first important so that's what we call
this hot 50 list so you we should at all
times have a list of the hot 50 people
that we want to get in touch with right
now we have a list of the hot 50 people
who want to get in touch with now this
needs to be realistic it can't just be I
want to be in touch with Oprah well okay
well remember you make it realistic so
that you can actually hit these goals so
maybe if you're just starting up in a
field like neuroscience or in
cryptocurrency or in meditation and
spirituality maybe what you want to do
is you want to go up one or two or maybe
three levels not jump 10 or 20 levels to
Oprah but jump just one to three levels
up to someone that is already a figure
in the neuroscience space are already a
figure in the cryptocurrency space maybe
they already have their business maybe
they already go and do meditation and
spirituality talks maybe they do
workshops so these are the people that
you want to put on your list and reach
out to and move fast with this don't
just make the list and then say I'll do
it later I mean move fast how bad do you
want to identify with your Northstar how
quickly do you want to move forth
towards the goals that you've set if you
want to get there fast and do your hot
50 fast and you'll understand more with
step number five but let's go to four so
we ask okay after I've identified this
list of hot 50 then what do I do well
you do your really strong powerful two
sentence emails so for example for
someone like us at the show we our
subject would be show invitation hey
Kyle love your work it Rock to feature
you on our show and SF and show is
hyperlink to our website so they have
somewhere to go in reference if you're
interested let me know a date that works
for
you done that's it that's the whole
email just like that two sentences so in
these emails to these hot 50 people they
don't have time to be looking through
paragraphs and paragraphs and paragraphs
of content just give them a very quick
value proposition mention how you
already have looked at their work and
now how you enjoy it send them your link
and provide them with that value
proposition that you have something to
provide them with something that will
entice them enough to want to set a time
to meet with you and it helps a lot if
you're already in the media space there
are so many people that say that you
need to be a media company you need and
this is this is this is becoming more
and more important with the internet and
with social media that you need to be
able to market yourself across those
platforms in order for your voice in the
attention economy to get the reach that
it needs for your ideas to disseminate
and for you to actually be able to
update the code of our world so having a
concise two sentence email with a value
prop is critical send that's all how
fifty people you make the ha fifty list
you send it to the people and you forget
about it because guess what happens in a
couple days maybe even the next day
you'll get two or three replies from
people saying sure I'd love to meet
here's a date that works for me and
you'd be surprised at how often this
works it's incredible even if the other
47 people some of them maybe just open
the email and then they learned about
you and didn't reply to you but now they
know about you other people may not have
just replied but again who cares
forty-seven people done no problem three
yes awesome move on next hot 50 so
that's the idea is that step number five
is to just straight-up repeat this
process are you in the earlier parts of
your career
are you still building out your network
do you still really want to connect with
people that are smarter and more
influential than you you need to go
through this process of vertical
networking and hop 50 as frequently as
possible in order for you to connect two
prominent nodes provide them with value
make those connections ask them for
referrals to other prominent nodes in
their network once you provide them with
that value and they see that and feel it
and enjoy it and then repeat this
process over and over again we still
have a list of hot 50 we're gonna keep
having a list of hot 50 as you keep
leveling up
you're going to keep reaching up a
couple levels every single time you
level up and so it's critical to go
through this process and I hope that
this process has been insightful for you
everyone just remember identify what
your purpose is in this world your
puzzle piece is critical for
civilization to flourish and so identify
what the North Star is and go forth with
the process of creatively endeavoring
into the world to bring forth your
unique gifts we need you here are some
of the trips the tricks and tips for you
with vertical networking in ha 50 feel
free to leave me your thoughts in the
comments below I'll go and reply to
those that I can and share this content
with other people if you know
entrepreneurs artists educators
scientists anyone that's trying to reach
their goals share this content with them
help them understand how to vertically
Network in to reach out be fearless be
fearless it's so important you're gonna
miss 100 percent of shots in life you
don't take take the shots at these hop
50 take the shots with next ones share
the content with other people get them
inspired to build the future as well
thank you for tuning in and you can find
the rest of simulations links below to
all of our other thought-provoking
interviews and other content that we
host on this channel I'm your host Don
sake and thanks very much for tuning in
and we'll see you soon peace